'Sup, guys?
Wait a minute...
You guys aren't the real Avengers!
I can tell, Hulk gives it away.
That was awesome!
Did Liz get a new top?
No. We've seen that before.
Never with that skirt.
We should probably stop staring before it gets creepy though.
Yeah.
Too late.
You guys are losers.
So, to become an Avenger, are there like trials or an interview?
Just don't do anything I would do
and definitely don't do anything I wouldn't do.
There's a little gray area in there and that's where you operate.
Oh.
All right?
That's not a hug, I'm just grabbing the door for you.
Alright, kid, good luck out there.
Listen, I know school sucks.
Peter! You still with us?
- Uh, yeah, yeah.
I know you want to save the world.
But...
You're not ready yet.
You're the Spiderman.
No, I'm not. I'm not.
This is just a costume! This is...
You were on the ceiling!
Stay close to the ground.
And stay out of trouble.
Forget the flying monster guy.
There are people who handle this sort of thing.
I'm sick of him treating me like a kid all the time.
But you are a kid.
This is my chance to prove myself.
Peter, what is going on with you?!
I'm really sorry, I'm so busy, I'm slammed.
Don't mess with me, because I will kill you
and everybody you love.